canadian prime minister justin trudeau
left little doubt about the nature of a
truck attack on sunday
that killed four members of a muslim
family he called it
an act of terrorism an incident that
could have been defined as a local hate
crime
elevated to the status of a national
tragedy
as canadians we make a pact
with one another that we will look out
for each other
take care of each other respect
each other well for the muslim canadian
community
that pact has been broken
too many times islamophobia
is real
racism is real
hours before attending a vigil for the
victims in london ontario trudeau was on
the floor of the canadian parliament in
ottawa
where he promised to go after and
dismantle hate groups
and curb online hate speech that has
fueled islamophobia
and hate crimes leaders from across the
political spectrum pledged to do the
same
but conservative politicians taking the
mic were
forced to speak over the booing crowd
[Music]
many blame canada's conservative leaders
of inflaming hatred
for political gain on behalf of the
people of ontario
of a province left in mourning
i'd like to extend my deepest sympathies
leader of the new democrats jagmeet
singh who ran against trudeau in the
last election
received a much warmer welcome
[Applause]
we have children that are worried that
they might look too muslim if they wear
a hijab
this act of terror was committed with
the purpose
of driving fear into the hearts of the
muslim community
so i want to say to my sisters that
we're a hijab
to my brothers that wrap their head
we will not cower in fear we will wear
our turbans
our hijabs with pride because we are
proud of who we are
members of the muslim community shared
words of hope but also
anger at what they describe as systemic
and prevailing
islamophobia we are all victims of
perverse
islamophobia or pervasive and perverse
islamophobia in our society
and we all pay a price for that hatred
we
cannot be satisfied as long as our
national security agencies
still seem more obsessed with us than
those that are killing us
the vigil paused for a moment of silence
at 8 40 p.m local time
the same moment two days earlier as the
attack on the afzal family
who went out for a walk and never made
it home
zain basravi al-jazeera